hey everyone this is Kevin from the test
website comm and today we're going to be
looking at a nice little gambit called
the Smith more game it and if you're not
too familiar with it it's a game but
from white against the black defense the
Sicilian defense and if you've played
chess for any amount of time and you
play e4 like I do you run into the
Sicilian quite a bit and if you're like
me playing the Sicilian is pretty
frustrating I actually prefer a move
like beef or even the French defense
East six I really don't like playing the
Sicilian defense and so I started
playing the Smith more gambit quite
frequently now because I feel like it
gives white a lot of aggressive lines to
play and at the same time it's going to
take black completely out of any
Sicilian defense lines that they've
thought about trying against you so
let's go ahead and start out it starts
out with E for from white and black
responds e5 and this is the Sicilian
defense and from here White's going to
play d4 and after black captures on d4
White's now going to offer up a nother
pawn on c3 and after black captures on
c3 then why it's going to recapture with
his knight on c3 and as you can see here
this is the Smith war gambit we've given
up two pawns and blacks giving up one
pawn but as you can see we already have
Center control with our pawn at the same
time we have a nice night on c3
developed and it has nice central
control now from here I just want to go
over some of the main themes in the
Smith Moore gambit we're visually going
to want to bring our Bishop to this c4
Square and we're going to want to attack
this f7 Square this is a huge weakness
for black anytime in the opening and we
want to go ahead and attack that as soon
as possible at the same time we want to
bring our knight to f3 and then we want
to Castle kingside
at the same time we want to move our
queen a lot of times we'll move our
queen after our Bishop our LightSquared
Bishop comes out and we want to control
the C file in the D file with our rooks
anytime you have a
half-open file a semi-open file or a
full open file this C file is a full up
and file or semi open file on the D file
you want to control those with your rook
so we'd really like to bring our a rook
to the C file bring our H rook to the D
file once we castle and get our pieces
all developed and from there we're going
to have a very aggressive game the
entire game black is going to be behind
in development and so anytime you play a
gambit you're always going to want to be
aggressive so if you're not a very
aggressive player by nature I don't
recommend this life at all but if you
are a very aggressive player and you
don't like playing against the Sicilian
and the main Sicilian lines I highly
recommend you give this a try so I'm
going to go over two of the main lines
that you may see in the Smith more game
it and now I'm going to go over a few
other variations that you may see or
that you can do if you're feeling very
very aggressive and you just want to try
out some different stuff so from here
you may see the knight to c6 from black
simple development move and from here
we're going to bring our Knight to f3
and then the pawn is going to come to d6
and White's going to bring his Bishop to
c4 again remember we want to velop our
LightSquared Bishop at the same time we
want to Castle kingside and attack this
f7 pawn so from here blacks going to
play e6
trying to defend indirectly this pawn on
f7 so that we can't attack it with our
bishop right away and from here we're
going to Castle kingside get our rook
into the action like eventually to bring
it to this D file if we can and blacks
going to develop his Knight to f6 we're
going to bring our Queen's at e2 since
our Bishop has been developed to c4 and
Black's going to play his Bishop to e7
so the heat can Castle kingside
eventually we're going to bring our rook
to d1 getting ready for the battle from
here Black's going to continue up the
middle try to block off some of our
paths with pawn to e5 and from here we
can it we can do a few things we can
develop our dark square Bishop and then
bring our rook into the action or we can
start an attack on the black King
already it's really up to you any time
you're playing an aggressive opening
like the Smith more gambit you can
really attack when you start getting
your pieces into the mix so that's one
defense you may see another defense you
may see is called the Chicago defense
the Chicago defense is defense I've come
across quite a few times playing the
smith board gambit in black first plays
pawn to e6 and he does this because he
knows we eventually want to bring our
Bishop to c4 and he wants to right away
say that hey I want to protect this pawn
on f7
a lot of times players playing black
will try to wait but in the Chicago
defense black right away it tries to say
hey I'm going to protect this by playing
pawn to e6
so from here Y can just continue with
Bishop to c4 still attacking this long
diagonal and from here blacks I want to
play a six with intention to bring his
pawn down to b5 attacking our bishop on
c4 from here we're going to continue
development of our Knight to f3 and
Black's going to continue with his plan
with pawn to b5 attacking our Bishop
we're just going to bring it back to b3
and then blacks going to play his pawn
to d6 and we're going to Castle kingside
and if you look at the Chicago defense
which is very popular in the Smith for
gambit you can see here we have three of
our minor pieces developed we have a
nice little pawn on e4 and we have
castle on the King side and black has
four of his pawns move but he has none
of his pieces moved a lot of times when
players play against the Smith more
gambit it's a very passive defense that
they try and it just really doesn't work
there's so many aggressive lines that
white has that he can be creative with I
feel it's really hard for black to
always prepare against all the attacks
that White has in the
more gamut so that's the Chicago defense
if you're playing the Smith more game
and you want to play even more
aggressive then you have an additional
option and the Smith more gambit after
d4 and he takes and he takes again on c3
you can now bring your Bishop to c4
right away and if you played a lot of
the Danish game before it kind of has
those same kind of lines that we've
talked about in the Danish gambit but
from here after he takes on b2 then we
can take with our Bishop on b2 and as
you can see here now we're down to ponts
an additional pawn over the smith more
gambit mainline but from here we have a
lot of attacking lines we can bring our
Queen into the action to support either
of these bishops at the same time we can
Castle kingside
fairly soon and we have a lot of
attacking lines yes we are down to pawns
but all our bishops are aimed right at
the black King and blacks is going to
have a really hard time trying to defend
this now if you play correctly yes you
are down to pawn so it's going to be not
the easiest game especially if you're
playing someone really good but at the
same time blacks really going to have to
play really well to defend against all
your attacks but at the same time he
does not have to accept the the game so
if he plays c5 and then he takes on d4
and then we offer up the extra pawn he
can play one of two things sometimes you
may see Knight to f6 and then from here
we can play pawn to e5 attacking and
then if he comes to d4 excuse me d5 then
we can recapture and that's one of the
things you'll see or another thing you
may see is after we play c3 he may play
d3 and then we take back with our queen
and either way if he does decline in the
Smith more game he's going to be
completely out of his Sicilian defense
lines that he's used to playing so if
you hate playing against the Sicilian
defense or you just want to add another
gambit to your repertoire if you're a
very aggressive player I definitely
recommend the Smith more game it I've
had a lot of success with it and I
definitely like to hear how it works for
you yet so I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you haven't already please
subscribe and I'll see you guys in the
next video thanks for watching everybody